scarlett johansson is suing disney calm
yourself
it's not quite as big a deal as i think
a lot of people assume it is
so scarlett johansson has sued disney
over
breach of contract because of the way
that black widow was released basically
what it boils down to is
the way her contract and payout works
she gets
a percentage of the box office release
however the box office from theaters
is undercut by the fact that it was also
released at streaming at the same time
which is not part of her contract this
does not mean she now has massive grudge
against disney this doesn't mean she has
a problem with kevin feige
those things are possible but it's not a
given and she is far from the first
celebrity
filmmaker star what have you to sue over
a change in release
it's become an ongoing issue in the age
of streaming and it's just something
that
uh we're gonna keep seeing another thing
that probably makes this far less of an
issue is
her contract is up with disney anyway so
it's not like she's gonna walk out on
projects
so there you go not that big a deal